I'm obsessed with the idea of doing
something new in the world of Jennifer's
Body it's interesting how she says it's
something in the world of Jennifer's
Body it leaves open a lot of
possibilities perhaps some demonic power
keeps Jennifer alive or brings her back
to life but maybe she's only being kept
alive in spirit through her former
friend after she's killed in Jennifer's
Body we learned that nidi inherited some
of her powers most occult Scholars don't
know this but if you're bitten by a
demon and you live you just might absorb
some of the Demon's abilities for needi
this seems to include levitation and
super strength but for Brook morio
moving to Minnesota and Reinventing
herself as Diablo Cody was necessary for
her to break out of her bubble and take
a step forward professionally she no
longer feels the need to use that name
in her personal life but still
occasionally calls upon that alter EA
Jennifer's Body has become a cult
classic in the horror community